[Music]
let's meet me at 6:00 well do some
squats fer absolutely not in real life
Wolverine knows Schwing Schwing Schwing
Schwing Schwing
submitted by boogie all night harvard
university uncovers a DNA switch that
controls genes for whole body
regeneration I need new to new kneecaps
and two new ankles right now okay here
go all right because it made from stem
say oh no it's not stem sales so there
was this genetic study this type of worm
a work it's called three-banded panther
most of that she is a so scientists
discovered that a section of their junk
DNA controls a mastered controlled gene
called early growth response er Eve G
art it acts like a switch that turns
regeneration on or off and so what they
discovered is that humans also carry
this gene as well why don't we carry it
if we don't even use it maybe we had it
before in the past maybe our arm would
fall off and then we need a new one we
have a son of genes actually and a lot
of them are just turned off Wow yeah
they're close they call them junk genes
it'll why they don't forget DNA because
like when we were different kind of
species we had them so it's in the
memory of our history but then like why
like are we gonna turn it back on like
if like we don't need no no well if we
turn this on then it would turn
regeneration on I know but why did it
there not as an example not complete
regeneration but growth an uncontrolled
growth are is a sequence that turned on
and that's cancer and ears and noses
well they all have their own genetic
sequence II let me tell you something I
saw this documentary and this was like
over 10 years ago
but I do remember one little section ok
they're like trying to figure out
immortality and they were studying the
immortality jellyfish Lobster back to
what you said about turning off that or
turning on the gene or or being able to
live immortally like what they do will
speed up the cancer and human beings
also its population control maybe
oh no he's saying that the organism
itself won't die much faster
you know tell me how did the - yeah yeah
yeah that's what we don't have it on yes
then if it is turn on it's like
population control yes but more like we
all die yeah we all die more like
everybody more like yeah epidemic so
here's this question that homie how do
you tell me so you had that option of
turning on this gene where you just
essentially could regrow anything that
you want you become the superhuman but
your life expectancy is only 35 years
would you trade that for your life now
from this point no because I turn it on
right now and I'm already like this 35
years from the moment you were born on
there no man that's not enough years I'm
35 now and I feel like I'm just living
my life I love that okay 50 till you're
50 homie that's not enough well you know
what I want I want to be like alter
carbon would be enough how many years 73
that's it
what for always that's like a good deal
I want to be like alter carbon and then
take it in oh and then go Jax I want to
show me like some matrix mmm second
alter carbon on Netflix it's amazing
really yeah that's actually a really
good sci-fi [ __ ] series well if you
don't like sci-fi you won't understand
like what Westworld harry potter she
said thank you
West world I didn't watch it yet Ultra
glass world okay Dwight you watch the
first like five minutes
we didn't like it I was gonna keep
watching well you said all these Asians
are too sexy she got too hard yeah
that's a Geo statement you're like Bart
this is making me too horny we got to
change unless they should control what
they're doing I would regenerate I
wasn't what gene was if we had great
regeneration I think I'll people will
live a lot more recklessly horse yeah I
would be doing a lot more extreme sports
did you guys ever watch heroes that's
another one that I love lights heroes
yes here is this a fire isn't it it's
supernatural have superpowers let's uh
consider sci-fi fantasy that's fantasy
that's just I don't consider that
scientific watch you don't even we're
talking about it's a superhero stuff
that's probably fantasy I wouldn't
consider that science fiction though
it's okay
you guys win just says American totally
you know it just says American
television I think they're right if
American television science fiction
television that's not science fiction
according to Wikipedia real sci-fi fans
out there is that science fiction or not
it's a person [ __ ] either nut cookies
so our wafers cookies or not Nilla
wafers just wafers the styrofoam with
all the layers no [ __ ] three
benefactors and six oh wait mater the
[ __ ] mayor
someone from your guys's team agreed
with us that's what but she's she's
happened half from your guy his team not
my team batch
she also bakes yeah baby way birds yeah
I brought up heroes she's an authority
unstable foundation David team badge no
no it's not like at least one let's
table we I brought up heroes because
they have a character that hayden
Panettiere yeah don't you still argue
about that [ __ ] oh the dolphin girl done
she's not a dolphin she what absolutely
is really high thing and then jumped off
as she just goes she can't die so that's
cool we're going back to the
regeneration thing here I remember a
video of her in a pool of dolphins
screaming a Japanese people yeah really
yeah because they slaughter the Japanese
yeah they killed dolphins and then all
of a sudden hated Pentair was protecting
adolphus days well cuz they cornered
them into this cave and then they just
start like hacking oh yeah they start
killing if she there's so many that the
blue water turns red so much blood yeah
it's really tragic it's a I guess
tradition for this little fishing town
and then they already call it corral the
dolphins into the coast and then they
have this like festival yeah it's like
what is it it's like a bay so then they
they corral them through the ocean and
then they come up here so then they're
like pushed up against the sand and then
they they kill them I just picked up
well-being baby dolphins for some reason
this makes it that are in my head baby
you dolphin dolphin you know baby sharks
huh no but okay I wafer is called a
wafer cookie thank you now I'm confused
well it's a David unstable foundation
you have
people I forgot - [ __ ] [ __ ] right now
I take it back I take it back you take
it back
- Lee you want to be a part of the
3-minute Panthers or what well we can do
that - we're the three this way though
[Laughter]
some ideas why I can't even do my Diaz
why it makes you uncomfortable you are
nasty makes me feel really comfortable
but she said what are you best I'm nasty
oh yeah why does this look so familiar
[Laughter]
after you bring it in anyways guys you
guys are so sick dude
Megan Brian I've got to go in the order
of pungency your God it has to be that
bad this is oh yes virginity for a life
right when the pink one in the stink no
[ __ ] the pungent nurse wouldn't be in
this pink yes we got to go in the order
of pungency this one's light and then
this was dark goddamn I'm smiling the
way I was going in the hospital holy
water after you do JK news oh I know I
do feel dirty after this but if you guys
have the option to yes yes on I'll do it
no I'm going into it I hate [ __ ] with
[ __ ] that that's like not yeah it's just
like God [ __ ] I hate [ __ ] one that's
I'm not natural yeah birth control [ __ ]
it Justin - Justin take birth control oh
that's what saves you just want to [ __ ]
with our home own titties but I don't
she was like oh yeah I forgot I don't
[ __ ] with the things God gives me but I
got it yeah
other than that though I don't do
anything else you probably see it as
like a ear pierced yeah I don't think
it's when you [ __ ] like they're hormones
is different yeah yeah if I could take
it out it's not affecting my life I will
say this bill I think like that's one of
those operations that if you do it right
it looks very good yeah first it's like
stuff where you start to [ __ ] with your
face sometimes and it gets a little
wonky or if you get marbles in your dick
that's the worst just hear them or you
can tell when they're getting a boner in
this room no no not at all
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]